es hora de trabajar algunos ejercicios
sobre expresiones radicales y bueno
todos estos ejercicios vienen desde la
canaca de mean así que vamos a leer el
primero simplifica la expresión
eliminando todos los factores que sean
cuadrados perfectos dentro de los
radicales y combina los términos si la
expresión no se puede simplificar
introducirla como está muy bien y tengo
menos la raíz de 40 más la raíz de 90
así que vamos a trabajarlo juntos y lo
primero que se me ocurre es ponerles
aquí menos la raíz de 40 déjame ponerlo
así ya esto le voy a sumar la raíz de 90
y bueno qué te parece si a cada una de
estas dos raíces
buscamos algunos factores que sean
cuadrados perfectos y aquí en esta que
tengo inicialmente lo primero que veo es
que es divisible entre 4 y 4 es un
cuadrado perfecto de hecho me quedaría
lo mismo que menos
es cuadrada de 4 x 10 x 10 y bueno pasa
algo muy similar con esta raíz de 99 es
un cuadrado perfecto por lo tanto voy a
escribir esta raíz como la raíz de 9 por
10 de lujo y bueno observa que el 10 no
tiene factores que sean cuadrados
perfectos si hacemos toda la
factorización completa en primos de 10
bueno pues 10 es lo mismo que 2 por 5 y
ninguno de los dos son cuadrados
perfectos así que en este caso observa
que 10 no tiene factores que sean
cuadrados perfectos y bueno esto mismo
entonces lo puedo escribir de la
siguiente manera como menos la raíz
cuadrada de 4 que multiplica a la raíz
cuadrada de 10 y bueno
observa que cuando digo la raíz cuadrada
de 4 estoy hablando de la raíz principal
de la raíz positiva de 4 ya esto le voy
a sumar la raíz cuadrada de 9 por la
raíz cuadrada de 10 de lujo y ahora
quiero ser muy claro porque la raíz
cuadrada de 4 o la raíz principal de 4
es lo mismo que 2 lo voy a poner con
este color y pasa lo mismo para esta la
raíz principal de 9 straits y entonces
esto me va a quedar de la siguiente
manera me va a quedar como menos 2 esto
de aquí es menos 2 dejan escribir lo
menos dos veces la raíz cuadrada de 10
más 3 veces tres veces la raíz cuadrada
de 10 3 veces la raíz cuadrada de 10
ahora más y tenemos menos 2 veces algo
más 3 veces ese mismo algo bueno eso es
lo mismo que una vez ese algo que una
vez
y es cuadrada de 10 en este caso así que
esta sería mi respuesta o inclusive
bueno este último paso si no lo
entiendes muy bien lo puedes ver de la
siguiente manera como tres veces la raíz
cuadrada de 10 ya esto le quitamos dos
veces la raíz cuadrada de 10 2 veces la
raíz cuadrada de 10 y cuantos esto bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que 3 de algo
menos 2 de algo eso es lo mismo que una
vez es algo que en este caso es la raíz
cuadrada de 10 y ya está
llegamos a la misma respuesta o
inclusive lo puedes ver de la siguiente
manera también hay otra forma de verlo
qué te parece si en lugar de hacer esta
operación factor izamos la raíz cuadrada
de 10 es decir utilizamos la propiedad
distributiva al revés y me quedarían
esto es lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada de
10 esto lo voy a sacar como factor que
multiplica quien bueno multiplica a 3 y
multiplican a menos 2 y ya está
3 - 2 esto
que uno me va a quedar una vez la raíz
cuadrada de 10 entonces todo esto aquí
se simplifica simple y sencillamente a
la raíz cuadrada de 10 muy bien qué te
parece si quito este de aquí y vamos a
hacer otro más y vamos a hacer este de
aquí dice simplifica la expresión
eliminando todos los factores que sean
cuadrados perfectos dentro de los
radicales y combinan los términos ok
esencialmente lo que me están
preguntando es lo mismo que tenía en el
ejercicio anterior y bueno pues vamos a
ver qué podemos hacer con esta expresión
que tengo aquí dice que tengo la raíz
cuadrada de 1 entre 96 a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por la raíz cuadrada de 3 y
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es que
podemos bueno esto es exactamente lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de 1 sobre 96
1 sobre 96 que multiplica a 3
es decir si tengo dos raíces cuadradas
que se multiplican puedo multiplicar
primero lo que está dentro de las raíces
y después sacar de raíz cuadrada y si te
estás preguntando por qué pasa esto
bueno pues es por una propiedades
radicales tal vez lo ves más claro aquí
si tenemos uno sobre 96 esto elevado a
la potencia un medio que a su vez
multiplica a 3 elevado a la potencia un
medio
bueno pues recuerda que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que uno sobre 96
que multiplica a 3 todo esto elevado a
un medio es una de las propiedades de
los exponentes y estoy utilizando esta
misma propiedad justo aquí abajo tomarme
la raíz cuadrada principal y elevar a la
un medio es exactamente lo mismo y bueno
esto va a ser lo mismo que 'quien que la
raíz cuadrada
de 196 por 3 es lo mismo que tres sobre
96 y ahora observa tanto arriba como
abajo tenemos tercera déjame hacerlo con
este color la tercera de tres es 1 y la
tercera de 96 es 32 y entonces esto va a
ser exactamente lo mismo que tener la
raíz cuadrada de 1 sobre 32 ahora veamos
si podemos simplificar esto un poco
arriba me quedan la raíz cuadrada de 1
déjame ponerlo así voy a dividir la raíz
cuadrada tanto arriba como abajo arriba
me quedaría la raíz cuadrada de 1 y
abajo me quedaría la raíz cuadrada de 32
y bueno la raíz cuadrada de 1 es 1 y la
raíz cuadrada de 32 es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de 16 por 2 entonces esto
va a ser lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada
de 16
por 2 porque el 16 por 12 32 y entonces
ahora si podemos hacer lo mismo que
hicimos en el ejercicio anterior esto es
lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada de 16 por
la raíz cuadrada de 2 y como 16 es un
cuadrado perfecto me va a quedar
exactamente igual que 1 entre cuatro
veces 4 es la raíz principal de 16 4 por
la raíz cuadrada de 2 y esto es justo lo
que vamos a poner aquí aquí me va a
quedar 1 sobre 4 por la raíz cuadrada de
ahora qué te parece si hacemos uno más
así que traigamos el último ejercicio y
si observas tenemos las mismas
instrucciones de la vez pasada así que
vamos a trabajar con esto que tenemos
aquí y bueno si lo observas una forma de
ver esto déjame escribirlo de nuevo aquí
la raíz cuadrada de 128 entre 27 es la
siguiente 128 es lo mismo que déjame
ponerlo así 64 por 2 y 64 es un cuadrado
perfecto así que me quedarían 64 por dos
abajo tengo 27 que es lo mismo que 9 por
39 por 3 y el 9 también es un cuadrado
perfecto y entonces tomó la raíz
cuadrada tanto arriba como abajo y me
quedaría la raíz cuadrada de 64 por 2 y
abajo me quedan la raíz cuadrada déjame
poner bien este por
9 por 3 y bueno después separar la raíz
y decir que esto es lo mismo que la raíz
cuadrada de 64 por la raíz cuadrada de 2
y bueno acá abajo me va a quedar la raíz
cuadrada de 9 por la raíz cuadrada de 3
esta es una forma de verlo y después
decir bueno yo sé que la raíz cuadrada
de 64 es 8 y la raíz cuadrada de 9
straits y entonces esto es lo mismo que
8 raíz cuadrada de 2 raíz cuadrada de 2
entre tres veces la raíz cuadrada de 3 y
ya acabamos y bueno puede ser que aquí
terminemos o también lo podemos ver de
la siguiente manera esto lo podemos ver
como 8 38 tercios de la raíz cuadrada de
dos tercios utilizando la misma
propiedad que hizo que dividiéramos aquí
la raíz cuadrada y ya acabamos bueno
déjame ver simplifica la expresión
eliminando todos los factores que sean
cuadrados perfectos dentro de los
radicales muy bien ya lo hicimos es este
8 y es este 3 y combina los términos
bueno eso en el caso de que tengamos
sumas y restas así que en este caso creo
que ya terminamos es una buena respuesta
poner ocho tercios de la raíz cuadrada
de dos tercios y hemos acabado